voici la renault 30 ts premier véhicule
de grande diffusion qui regroupe en
série la traction avant un moteur 6
cylindres en v d'une cylindrée de 2660
quatre centimètres cubes une direction
assistée plus les vitres teintées et le
pare brise feuilleté
[Musique]
l'essai de la renault 30 va se dérouler
en trois parties la conduite avec une
démonstration par un pilote expérimenté
aujourd'hui olivier gendebien la
sécurité en pleine collaboration avec
les techniciens de la prévention
routière et comme 1975 est l'année de la
femme
l'opinion de madame souvent
prépondérante dans l'achat d'une voiture
[Musique]
maman de la sécurité de l'a39 voici la
carcasse on trouve à l'arrière de
longeaux capable de transmettre un choc
arrière en l'absorbant par
l'intermédiaire de la traverse arrière
une traverse à l'avant assure la liaison
des longerons les sollicitant
formellement en cas de collision dans
l'éventualité d'un tonneau des poutres
latérales soudé au pavillon agissent
comme les arceaux de sécurité d'une
voiture de rallye et sur les côtés la
rigidité du montant est confirmée par
l'importance de ce qu'on appelle le pied
dont il est la suite
l'art est inférieur de la planche de
bord est incliné si vous leur thé pas de
choc
mais en cas de choc le boîtier de
direction recul mais pas le volant dont
la conception permet une bonne
visibilité des instruments les pédales
sont larges et bien séparés l'habitacle
est vaste les ceintures sont en couleur
mais pour l'accrochage le passage me
paraît assez étroit pour la main le
levier de vitesses et trapu et je passe
la première pour partir en essonne
fresnes
c'est ce qu'on appelle un freinage bien
en ligne à tiens j'oubliais on peut
verrouiller les portes de l'intérieur
par un contacteur syli ashok le
déverrouillage est instantané quant à la
maniabilité malgré un certain volume le
temps de ts se comporte vraiment bien
dans les situations les plus inattendues
[Musique]
la capacité du coffre de la renault 30
et comme vous le prouvent ces images
très largement suffisante
[Musique]
je ne peux pas considérer cette voiture
comme une voiture particulièrement
féminine s'est pourtant souvent nous les
maires qui sommes chargés de conduire la
petite famille en vacances et je peux
vous assurer que la voiture est très
confortable tant pour le pilote que pour
les passagers arrière
j'ai été séduite par la facilité de
conduite grâce à la direction assistée
et aussi grâce à la boîte automatique
[Applaudissements]
et
vous voyez que pas du confort cette
voiture qui est quand même très
confortable nous avons une suspension
qui là je le reconnais est absolument
remarquable
ça veut dire je sais peut-être au
détriment de ceux que les couloirs de
bill comme je l'étais après si rond
point du tout ni doute mais l'atelier
doute à l'heure actuelle où normalement
on doit pas dépasser les 130 à leurs
soirées in what 90 sur des routes
sinueuses comme celle ci est bien la
tenue d'autres exemplaires tout en ayant
insiste une très bonne dispersion
évidemment si on voulait rouler au
maximum des possibilités la voiture
c'est à dire à 185 environ à deux
vitesses pareil 6 à 4 personnes en
voiture
elle est un peu molle à mon avis je
voudrais vous dire maintenant que le
soyez en plein jour l'impression qu'on
m'a fait cette voiture de nuit je les
conduis denis rapidement sur des routes
sinueuses et là j'étais épaté par
l'amélioration non seulement de la
luminosité du fait d'effets arrion mais
du système de compensation déquilibre
parce que la voiture est chargé
maintenant je peux vous parler de
l'accélération
je vais pas vous faire une démonstration
de l'accélération
c'est quand même une voiture qui
développe 131 chevaux din ce qui est
absolument respectable
nous avons fait hier deux essais de
consommation elle a forcément savary non
seulement d'après le parcours n'a pas le
conducteur
enfin sur un parcours moyen routes et
autoroutes je suis arrivé moi en faisant
d'eux et c'est quand même d'accélération
de voitures elles consommation de
environ 14 litres ce qui est raisonnable
voire moteur v6 avec une accélération
comme ceux ci à d'autres termes cette
voiture est pour moi au prix où la régie
quand la vendre
ce que j'ai vu de mu jusqu'à présent sur
le marché automobile
la renault 30 vos clés en main tout
compris trente cinq mille cinq cents
francs
[Musique]